esiste ormai nella mia vita una realtà
molto strana vero sentire la mia voce in
contesti che non centrano una sega e di
ricatti ma cosa sono io vi sto parlando
di tik tok nel senso che ormai sapete
tutti come funziona tik tok ovviamente
la gente usa degli audio o canzoni robe
per i balletti insomma delle cose dove
poi sopra ci fai degli sketch ci sono
alcuni di questi segmenti di audio che
hanno più successo di altri in
particolare l'ultimo che sta avendo un
successo planetario e con planetario
intendo planetario perché veramente e
più famoso tipo in russia che in italia
e non sto scherzando ci sono io che dico
e leo di sisma house di satana is my
friends e mi sono ritrovato tantissime
persone che me lo stanno segnalando che
tipo in russia tik tok air famosissimi
nel mondo utilizzano la mia voce per
fare appunto degli sketch che mi fa
ridere che ogni tanto io apro tik tok e
mi compaiono delle modelle stragnocche
russe che usano la mia voce mi fa molto
piacere questo soprattutto mi fa ridere
che in russia utilizzino i miei
contenuti e sti cazzi quando a me invece
hanno buttato giù la reaction di ciao
tarda ma passiamo quindi alla revisione
di questi fantastici contenuti a
partiamo 1 random house
is
my friends non so perché viene
utilizzato comunque per per gli animali
la maggior parte delle volte tra l'altro
notato che in molti tik tok si utilizza
l'albero di natale visto che è un trend
natalizio perché i cani e gatti lo
massacrò compreso il mio è che il mio
albero è morto praticamente prova bene
che carino
già un po i denti da satana precari noah
pronto mi sento un po davy five four che
re acta video di bassi invece io reato e
gatti per
fusi si chiama easy se satana ma i
benvenuti
scusate scusate ogni tanto sono così
però andiamo avanti
sono tutti bellissimi perché gli animali
solo così bene a questo senza il mouse
mai ferma
lì non ha capito gli è successo niente e
bellissimo
questa è la faccia questa è la faccia di
chi si è svegliato da un secondo
ma
sbaglia mai sbagliato tutto non c'è la
casa non c'è neanche l'animale domestico
o quello nè casa tua non può essere casa
tua
madonna
belli è bellissimo e leo questo lo so di
questo questo lo so leggere allora
allora non lo so leggere scatta comunque
è finto non è vero quell'animale di asus
g60 è vero ha chiuso gli occhi sembrava
un pupazzo ragazzi era un pupazzo fino
all'inizio del video guarda cioè non può
essere vinto
non può essere un metodo di silente
ragazzi è finto e finto come è arrivato
quest audio qui soprattutto come ragazzi
voi non avete idea di questo niente c'è
veramente sto visto audio è andato
everyware c'è altro che in russia è
finito anche in cui bechis ton
thesis
madonna che di notte io mica ge ray
addosso che la metà bassa ma va bene
quando perdi tempo a pulirla e renderla
carina ma lei decide di sporcarsi pochi
istanti evitarli
ah sì come mia mamma quando ripuliva da
piccolo
isis satana e va bene allora forse era
meglio l'albero caduto di notare ma tra
l'altro la cosa che mi fa ridere di
tutto questo che il mio cane ok perché
ho un cane chi non lo sapesse si
adatterebbe perfettamente
ma proprio a pennello a questa audio e
questa audio non proviene da un video
con il mio cane che è incredibile
e
bellissimo questo mio preferito in
assoluto guarda il cane dietro che si
finge morto per non far finta che non è
stato lui questo è il migliore tra tutti
in assoluto is my friends del contento
che gli frega no ma turno io cane
comunque una volta fatto una roba del
genere pare che con tutti contenti alla
fine non è importante
ma e greta menti questa segreta me e
greta menti russa
grechi schimmenti gli ski celebra niente
ho visto solo ragazze
incredibili e se mai dovesse incrociare
una di queste ragazze dove si fa mitico
cosa ti dico e mi riconosci un cazzo sei
è quello che
non è proprio il massimo per rimorchio
però va bene ragazzi direi che possiamo
concludere qua questa reaction a
animali e bambini che tirano robe ai
muri vabbè comunque sono contento che la
mia voce venga utilizzata per nobili
situazioni grazie mi raccomando smontate
l'albero di natale perché so che siete
pigri e non l'avete fatto prima che il
vostro cane velo tutti giù e dobbiate
utilizzare la mia voce per altri mesi
datevi una mossa ciao
[Musica]